we are back we are back we are back how
is everybody doing how you live and how
you feel and how you move in NFL one day
away from the Hall of Fame preseason
game between the Bears and their Athens
how are you can you feel it can you feel
it
I am I'm glad to be that close I mean
it's just it's always a great time of
the year it's summer we're talking
football the anticipation of the season
and yes I'm letting it ready to see live
action I don't expect any of the main
players to be playing tomorrow night and
that's just yeah which is fine because
we do we want to see some of these young
Jackson let's get to a little bit of
news and notes first everyone that
continues to this up on socials but
amazing at Sims love Coe tell your
friends download subscribe let's say
your friends tell your friends yeah
let's steal something from the barstool
guys they got one thing right I
subscribe unsubscribe and then re
subscribe it sends you higher on the
list Wow that's what they do
yeah that's some [ __ ] but I like it
let's steal that [ __ ] I like a
little quick injury note you were just
telling me that Jordan Matthews was
released from the New England Patriots
this is were recording Wednesday
afternoon
Josh dachshund out 5 to 6 weeks with a
broken collarbone Wow big time that is
big time
I thought about two things for one thing
for each of them right Dez Bryant now
would love to go to washing no doubt
about they need him in Washington now
what doc said being hurt because they
were already relying on him but I look
at the Patriots wide receiving corps
Chris Hogan Edelman's missing four games
Kenny Britt Phillip Dorsett okay never
mind Malcolm Mitchell Cordero perishing
right now though is Malcolm Mitchell and
Kenny Britt I don't think are totally a
hundred percent either so that's the
issue they're gonna look at but
Washington for DES Washington for DES as
in Josh Norman on the same team yeah I
love it
that would be cool I hear you hey des
there's something to his game certainly
that's going to be valuable I mean him
on the outside as a physical wide
receiver being able to catch back
shoulder balls things like that 51
t-ball's he is still very good about
that and that would be a team I would
look at those seriously I would think
consider them because you're all
Richardson your speed guy Jamison
crowded your ACL injury let's not refer
get Paul Richardson jr. tore his ACL
last year late in the season no like I'm
gonna say it was Midway maybe because I
had Paul Richardson of my fantasy TV was
check to see I will but John's
dachshunds hurt and then after that it's
Brian quick Robert Davis Maurice Harris
I think they have a legitimate need for
Dez Bryant yes III don't you think he
could fit into a Jay Gruden Oh like do
you think you fit into that office I do
and I think Jay is the type of coach too
that it would just all in all I think
Jay in that organization is the type of
organization that can handle that type
of personality right I mean they're
handling Josh Norman for a single game
last year Paul Richards I mean he tore
his ACL in 2015 that was three years ago
okay sorry good I was like nah man that
do was winning me games so then but they
got our Jameson Crowder there right yeah
that's what I'm saying is they need
another guy they do they got the speed
guy in Jameson crowd irk plays that
inside role you know the guy I think des
is the guy he gets that was twice he
gets Dallas twice that would be awesome
yeah it would be we have two interviews
coming up on today's show
one big Phil the big [ __ ] back the
other guy we've been talking about him a
lot this offseason and he wasn't on the
show I mean he wasn't he's out on a team
right now and I texted you and I said
what do you think could we get him and
man Chris Sims the best booking producer
that this company has probably is in
this corner we're getting a cornerback
who has recently knocked out a person
that works out at an airport
his name is Pacman Jones Wow yeah so
Pacman Jones coming up in about ten
minutes we're gonna call him he's always
been one of our favorite guests yes
tells it like it is doesn't care right
and I got a lot of questions yeah we do
and and let's help him out let's find a
team for exactly right I think that's
what we're going to do because he's
knowing pac-man through the years like
as competitive as they get I mean he's
he's a dog and what we would say in the
good way in the NFL I mean because he's
always ready to do bad
always always ready to compete have this
teammates back whatever it may be and
that's what I always respect about
pac-man so I do think there's some
mileage left in his career and and
really there's some teams that need
corners and I would certainly have him
towards the top of that list I was doing
research and the Bengals media was going
to the coaches and going do you think
you're gonna bring back pac-man Dre
Kirkpatrick is saying we might need to
bring him back
so even his former team it didn't end on
bad terms no they just have all these
young guys the cavalry Russells of the
world that they want to go could you be
our number four right because the
Bengals always have former first-round
picks I mean I still got what three on
the roster right now I mean as Denard
William Jackson and Dre Kirkpatrick
right yeah that's I mean it's but they
play a lot of for quarterbacks eh yeah
they do so those guys are coming what's
gonna be great ACL epidemic update
Denton dinner we're up to nine-niner
Jake Ryan tears his ACL for the Packers
out for the year yeah that's gonna be
tough they're gonna be going to some
inexperienced guys at middle linebacker
how important is middle linebacker for
Mike penton's offense for the PAS it's
pretty it's very important first of all
because it's the Mike Pettine defense
which first of all is what the Rex Ryan
defense to a degree right here I'm back
you're right and I would say really he's
he he has gone past Rex Ryan's defense
Rex Ryan at the end of Buffalo kind of
became yes not creative very we're just
gonna play man-to-man every play and I'm
gonna figure out some creative blitz
Mike Pettine does a lot of different
things the middle linebacker is huge in
that defense like so now it's gonna be
Blake Martinez hey Oren Burks yes third
round pick Owen Burke's not you know
young guys directing traffic and a
defense that can be complicated and you
know that's a defense that would the
David Harris's back in the day and
things like that yeah they value that
like middle linebacker that we grew up
in right not to tell them Smiths by
Nonna the thumper between the Tanners
Maya Trotter right right those kind of
guys and that's where Jake Ryan was he
was that guy for their team he added
some physicality at that position so he
kind of sucked up when you look at that
D line of the Packers yes with Kenny
Clark Mike Daniels Mohammad Wilkerson
and Clay Matthews putting his hand down
yes sir that's the reason why the
Packers were looking at a 10
win over under from Vegas because you
got Rogers and it was starting to click
yes they finally got some corners in
there some young ones but a little tough
loss they lose Jake Ryan but we are up
to nine ACL injuries he joins Fozzy
Whittaker Paul Warlow Hunter Henry
Morgan Fox Hercules madhava Nick bald
and Rod Taylor and Austin Roberts Mazar
your ACL nine thus far is that who they
were saying though but up there is it
gonna be the the when I was born Berks
is gonna be the guy he's impressive
coming out in the draft I mean he is
you're he's more towards your modern-day
NFL linebacker at Vanderbilt I do he's
very athletic he's gonna be a step up
actually for Jake Ryan in the pass game
the run game is where Jake Ryan he was a
beast in that part he was Hall of Fame
is this weekend full of Fame game is
Thursday night I wanna do a quick
preview and go I'm not looking to see
the new refreshed Joe Flacco I don't
know how much Mitchell Cho Biscay were
actually gonna see but do you think
we're gonna see a lot a little more
Jackson on Thursday night I do I expect
that's exciting yes sir that's a Hall of
Fame game that I'm tuning in for I would
think you're gonna see had they haven't
made a comment about who's playing right
I know that John Harbaugh he had said
about maybe 10 days ago that you know
none of their main starters were gonna
play I do question whether that's gonna
be you know a Joe Flacco appearance or
not if I'm the Ravens I probably don't
even play Joe Flacco in this one I go
first half RG 3 show us what you got
second half Lamar it's your show show us
what you got
because to abomb them as well you know
in RG 3 like the Teddy Bridgewater
conversation looks good right now right
they see it on the field see it on the
field and if he is really good and then
there's a few injuries at quarterback
and things like that then you get to the
week three or four the preseason and
some team goes you know what we need to
back up and RG three has been pretty
phenomenal over three weeks then he gets
into that compost conversation as well I
can't even this I was talking downstairs
with some Giants fans yeah I said the
best thing about drafting a guy like say
Quan Barclay is the preseason is so
exciting yeah cuz every time he touches
it it's awesome Colts quittin Nelson
it's gonna be fine but you're kind of
like am I really gonna watch the guard
on every play here right but Lamar
Jackson
this could be I I want him to run yeah
don't want him to run I don't want to
get hurt I won on the throw I hope that
if he does play first play we're dialing
up deep oh they're gonna I would they
show off his skill set you're gonna see
either his first pass I think will be
either play-action yep get the defense
to go way down the field if they cover
the deep post and oh man we get all this
take off or it's gonna be some torta
sort of bootleg where he gets to get
outside the pocket then set up free
behind a lot of thing right I'm excited
to see a little bit the Bears offense
sure I really want to see this Anthony
Miller kid yeah cuz everyone's talking
about this wide receiver out of Memphis
want to see him on the field I want you
loved him I loved him
I mean he's to me he was in that
conversation out of the out of the big
guys right I just want to make sure I
don't miss a you know DJ more DJ chart
yes Cameron Sutton the Cortland Sutton
sorry
and then really for me if I remember
correctly I mean Anthony Miller was the
next guy Anthony Miller is that he's
Jameson Crowder he's that guy tearing it
up a kid I'm not tearing it up I'm not
and I'm just curious to see you know
just Alan Robinson get out there yeah
what does this nagy offense look like
right where they gonna put tarik Owen it
should be exciting but the Hall of Fame
you texted me and said go on nfl.com
watch Randy Moss watch the best of Randy
Moss watch the best of tio and tell me
who's better I didn't have to watch I
literally watched like 40 seconds of
Randy Moss and when I've never seen
anybody do this I've never seen anybody
do it since it's not even close tio to
me always felt like his feet were on the
ground yes Randy Moss felt like he was
playing at a different strata that's why
it's to me watch the highlights yes it's
it's it I think it's very close and I'm
not sure really I do and I don't know
exactly was it closer after you watch
the highlights yes so you watched it and
actually question I was close going into
the highlights okay let me just say that
yes I was going I knew in my mind going
in I was like you know as I think about
this I bet utyos' highlights are gonna
be every bit as impressive if not more
the thing I that jumps out to me is the
impressive
highlights through a longer period of
time as you start to see Randy his
highlights become he's not really open
but he does a great job of going up and
jumping a 50-50 ball yes we're teo
really until the very last year or two
of his career was catching six yard
hitch routes and still making four
people miss and running for 65 yards
interest that's where I think it's very
close because I looked at it and when
every time the ball goes in the air it's
unbelievable Randy was making plays that
just didn't even make sense it doesn't
make sense especially when he would
catch the ball like in his waist yeah he
didn't even go up and get that and there
was two people around him and he still
caught and his waist has that other
people's top of their helmet yes so I
maybe maybe I watched it wrong Randy
Moss is highlights the high of the
highlights are more impressive that's
where I would say I guess you're saying
the consistency of the highlights of tio
mix makes it that close right I don't
think like tio is not not anywhere in
the stratosphere of naturally gifted
catcher like Randy mosses Randy Moss has
some of the best hands in the history of
the sport it's it's sick it's insane and
by the way in that highlight package you
know what randy said Revis always gets
double yes first of all it was 2009 that
right yeah Randy went down the middle of
the field there's no safety in the
middle of the field none they had him he
was on the island he was on that world
of his own it wasn't an island it was
like here's planet Earth cover Randy
Moss
so that disproves that theory but yeah I
mean Randy his ability to straight-line
speed catch 50/50 balls was unlike we've
seen anything in our in our lifetime up
to that point he was the first freak of
nature that came in at the receiver
position and you were like what well I'm
not used to seeing guys this size be
able to run this speed and jump and
adjust their body and all that kind of
things Macchio is a little bit more
handmade where he might have been every
bit as physically gifted like explosive
and all those things but he just wasn't
the natural gifted fluid athlete than
randy mosses and Tio's hands were
average that's where I always said I
mean I called the butterfingers great
can he agree because I talked I always
go back to this story the first time
ever CTO in person 2003 season we go
about to play San Francisco and he had a
100 yards and he made two catches and
they yack after the catch where I was
like damn that was like video game [ __ ]
like we were the Super Bowl champion
defense and he like weaved around like
Derrick Brooks and Ronde Barber and then
ran into the goalpost and fell down like
literally did that I was like holy crap
but he also dropped like seven catches
for an extra 200 yards we're like Jeff
Garcia put the ball right in his hands
and that I think is one of the things
that people don't know it's like if tio
got open got open a whole lot more right
then people realize like think about his
famous game against you know Steve Young
down the middle hey Connor
he caught it do you baby the theme of
the rest of that game he had a few big
drops don't touch the [ __ ] ball so
for them to go back to him right that's
why he cried after and all that so but
yes while that they go in the same year
yeah they both are playing with
legendary quarterbacks both legendary
running quarterbacks yeah tio starts off
with Steve Young Rainey ma starts off
with Randall Cunningham number two and
three and rushing touchdowns all-time
behind what quarterback rushing
touchdown yes for a quarterback but
those two guys they both start off right
they're both also playing with legendary
receivers top five top ten receivers and
Jerry Rice and Cris Carter on the other
side Bernie both were seen both wearing
a tie both were seen as troubling off
the field in different ways both had to
go all to different teams to kind of
make it work right their careers are are
mirrored in a way and they're going in
together but what's different now is I
read these articles about people
gleaning about their years they spent
with Randy Moss I read well swell Kerr
saying it was so cool to have him in and
reporters being like it was great
talking to Randy Moss I'm not seeing any
of that with TIA yeah right and I'm
gonna be watching it 3:17 I'm gonna find
a way to stream it I'm I will - yeah
no question about it 40 oh it's just
it's funny because he Oh had an
advantage over Randy in the fact that I
think he is physical workout regimen and
all that thing was a step up from Randy
throughout his career
I don't think Randy really got in that
into that towards the end where he was
like
Midas kills it excites almost a part of
you that goes if Randy Moss worked out
like tio could he have been even better
yeah I do to him crystal make me think
about that because I already think about
Randy as I can touch him but what I mean
he is untouchable but really ever I was
going with this story more than anything
and I do think this is where Randy
separates himself from @eo is Randy's
brilliant he's a football savant
he's brilliant Randy picked up the
Tennessee to our Tennessee Titans
offense Lona don't get me wrong when we
started tenon oh yeah no but this is now
this is 2010 and we're not very good ok
and he was on the Minnesota Vikings
remember after New England came to
Tennessee glass damn he picked up that
offense in like five days like it was
nothing to him and I just like Gronk in
that way he really is he is a savant I
mean he knew everything about the
offense and we I had a lot of good
conversations about we sat next to each
other on the plane yeah and all those
things really and that was the thing
that I what's he like as a person next
to on the plane oh he's cool he's chill
I mean Randy's I mean he's an icon he's
an urban legend even within the NFL
commit you know like Vic he really is
that way because he was a guy that could
kind of buck the establishment and they
were still like well you're a Randy Moss
go ahead and exactly right yeah that's
kind of power but when Randy got on the
on the plane and if he was wearing it's
to chill a jacket I mean everybody look
at Randy and he has that accent he does
but you'd always have something funny to
say as he's sitting down Randy had
gorgeous you guys had to fight over the
armrest no he got wherever he wanted to
sit and then I just said we're just
gonna say this yeah
taeo never drove into a police officer
taeo
I've never walked off on his team when
there was still time on the left and
said I play when I want and I really
think Randy did worse stuff and his kids
are more egregious I more egregious but
Tio's the one that's facing an arm we're
gonna call pac-man right now Madi in the
back Maddie took dimes if you can go
I'll pack is he still gonna be on yeah
let's say are you texting him right now
yep yes just making sure
thank good I like to ask I did pack face
both of these guys he probably did
I'm sure he did yes I mean yam I'm just
trying to think was he on the team with
cincy when wouldn t oo just like oh
we're both there we're gonna find out
what do we want to talk about big fills
the question all I got stuff oh you got
stuff you guys call them doom doom doom
yeah just call this call just call them
dial the freakin number okay and call
here we go I'm doing pretty good pretty
good I can't go play all right how you
how you feelin what's going on in your
life right now man working out raising
these kids this is my first first the
time where I had a decent amount of
break where I've been too been able to
fully engage with the kids since I had a
little bit more time but beside that man
is working are you going crazy yet like
are you at to the point yet where you're
like man what the hell is wrong with
these all 32 NFL teams and why the hell
don't they wanna me didn't they watch my
film might really like well be myself I
like to go just stay ready because I
know cars gonna come you know I'm 34
Bobby 35 years old had a hell of a run
in this game and I've made a lot of
money money is more of working I gonna
help a team win no no sir no I'm not
over here beating myself up or nothing
but um just staying ready man can't wait
to get the car you know yeah yeah so
first off Adam amazing name
I'm Adam - your parents were smart just
like my parents but I'm looking at the
Chargers they lose their cornerback who
what's his frickin name I'm forgetting
Jason Barret thank you and then I'm
seeing Trevor Williams goes down the leg
injury yesterday and and we had already
said on Mondays podcast they need to
call pac-man he'd be a perfect fit in
that defense do you see
to fit there possibly as well oh yeah
I'm very familiar it's almost a cover
three but it's got a lot more mixed in
it um actually I'm pretty cool with the
Y receiver there we talk maintaining
talking on a regular basis so I'm hoping
to go to a couple places but definitely
to play with the Chargers you know we're
full of ribbons over there you have a
guess but we'll see now you know it's
not as easy that we as we make it
sometimes I'm sure can you share with us
who you are talking to her you're gonna
keep that private
I'm gonna keep it to myself remember of
course everybody know that we we talked
to Cleveland Cleveland but we've got a
couple more calls and this week I've
actually got one today so I think we I
think we'll have some or something
before the end of the week or the
beginning of next week
you know yeah I see your guy Kirkpatrick
it was telling the media that that you
need to stay ready because we might be
calling you soon
so the Bengals might be calling you too
would you go back the next question
would you go back are you kind of sick
of their shenanigans all right that was
well done well done
yeah out of handle that by a
professional we were just talking about
Randy Moss and tio have you have you
faced both of those guys and do you have
a story of facing those guys Ricky here
in Tennessee and I never knew how fast
we go Bo you talk about like probably
the two best machines that I ever faced
I don't know who I want to put one into
but I know Manteo had have a great
relationship leads
a lot of things when I was in Dallas and
the work is the main thing like I
learned from - you're like regardless
what anybody say man they got taught me
how to be a pro you know I mean like
even today like today's when you don't
want to work you know I mean you waiting
on calls and you find a way to push
yourself to get to stuff so man I've
never seen four dollars what anybody say
is Forrest I'm so much that I play with
ya home Calvin Bosch was one of those
guys they worked little hard he wasn't
that I that I picked up a lot for him
but children regardless were anybody so
he was always working and I could go
over to his house and he'd be [ __ ] on
the bike for two hours after that
talking trash you know me so I picked up
a lot of heavy and a lot of good things
about around here that made me the
player that I am today so I have a lot
of respect for those guys our personal
relationship I would probably go with
you just because the person relationship
right you know I just said to follow up
on that a little bit because you talked
about Randy like just dealing with him
on the field you it was a straightaway
speed because you watch them on film and
those long strides are deceiving right
so oh yeah yeah right so like what what
was it about when you had a cover te oh
that jumped out to you more than
anything is it just as pure physical
strength or is there something else
there it was really good in and out of
his brakes and he ran them at the same
speed most of the time yeah when I had
when I had a chance to play practice and
go against them every day he used to
call me the neck like his zero turn over
one to get going oh my god I want to get
up to about 20 yards if it's a double
move or what it is whatever it is you
could throw it father you want I'm just
curious
Adam you line up against Randy Moss the
first time and you're sizing them up and
you're feeling good you know you're like
this big-time rookie and you're fast as
hell alright and what was the moment
that you realized Randy might even have
a gear on you
that he scored any score do they catch
it we caught one and that's when I
learned I better not go here leverage on
rank marks for the rest of the game my
leverage and made I made him beat me
outside like and I sold my safety to
plays after that I said look man if he
catch a go ball and he released inside
and he's still running inside that's on
you
right I said no you can't throw ball
outside and I'm gonna make sure you
don't catch a go ball if I'm on the
outside first but if you go inside you
better be able to lean over
I can't imagine all right so I got me on
the topic now and I know you do you know
you're still gonna be playing this year
and you might not want to give anybody
love but who is the guy that you've had
a faceoff here just in modern times
where you've been like man thank you
music so that's that's the next you know
that was the next biggest handful other
than tio or Randi that you've had it
cover to this point and I will put up
there with them to be like oh yeah AJ
right you know I have you have to go to
practice every day with AJ
are you asking me who it's gonna be hard
to feel those vibes you know I mean no
III get you because yeah I guess I guess
packed I kind of look at it like this oh
yeah they're number two and three
all-time as far as receiver however you
want to write them you're right
so I get you what about to play with
video three years though it's kind of
it's gonna be hard for me to say who can
you know I mean well what about what
about the Odell's the Antonio Browns the
Julio's are they even in their class
tell ya it's just a different it's just
a different game first of all yeah um
now when I first got into leaves you can
trust you Livermore right now you can't
touch nobody hmm and which is its
offensive League with everybody no but
of course Julio Jones is Julio AJ a B OH
that-that-that's the new century you
know I mean right right of course those
guys got a lot of work to do to be Keo
and Random House if you look at the the
numbers don't lie with the other random
or fake date they have they have done
what the number said they've done those
guys are very great good athletes um and
and they are the best of our generation
right now you get them saying yeah sure
yeah totally totally get you all right
well now I respect all of them all of
you got to wake up the play done you
don't wake up and play they're
embarrassing yeah I'm not saying well
I'm giving them I'm giving them the
cross but only thing I'm saying is that
that's two different generations yeah
yeah I hear you are you gonna talk to
pack me about how we got second place
where one of our awards well I wanted to
talk to him first I said no second place
in our best Instagram video of the off
season well it's really my favorite
Instagram video abilities speaking of
being physical with receivers and being
a gnat and a pain in the ass for people
please I mean we had so much fun I loved
watching you knock the crap out of that
guy at the airport so I know you didn't
write song sorry miss alline Wow I was
with my family like that was the most
heartbreaking part I was with my kids
and everything for him to approach me
and strike me in my face like that was
unbelievable but like I don't get no
points I'll be doing that like Mendes
that's what I'm saying like not bragging
and then I used to I used to fight every
day but like I don't I don't want to be
known as keep fighting like all right
I'm saying like yeah why should I have
to go through that [ __ ] in the airport
when I'm just walking with me in my
family like that [ __ ] is ludicrous you
know I mean and if I had more videos of
all the other stuff that I went through
now you know it's 2018 so everything is
on the camera I think but if I could
have half of the videos that I've got
into [ __ ] and the videos which came out
and you'll be the first
oh I know don't you worry well the first
thing that sim said was pac-man's like
the worst guy to try and fight with oh
he looks small oh he doesn't look big
he's gonna pack a punch and we were just
lacking did you know this guy like did
this come out of nowhere never met this
guy after my lawyer I'm not did a home
work with this lawsuit that we might be
shown he had just been in Atlanta for I
think three weeks when he was working
for the airport right now I've never met
this goddamn alert to your defense you
did you went to the limit I mean yes you
tried to avoid it we've seen the whole
video so you know if anybody ever tries
to turn that story against you know you
tried to be the professional the bigger
man he gave you no choice so you did
what I think every man would do at some
point there and with a backpack on who
gave him what he deserved you gave him
the man I love the jerk with the left
hand to pull him in and then throw the
right hook and then to break his leg I
mean that was just icing on the cake and
really I don't feel bad for him he
deserved it so I'm having fun talking
about it but that was impressive man
we'll stop talking about it
yeah well gosh that was awesome do you
care well I will say this before Adam I
think the thing that's annoying is when
someone starts a fight with you because
Adam is so well known
it's up he's fighting again we just want
Adam saying right and it wasn't caused
by him and that's where I could see it's
frustrating for you cuz it's like you
didn't create this you're just defending
and then when he pushes the female and
he pushes you that's what I'm saying is
you're not the defendant in this one I
mean you are the defend you're the one
that was kind of getting attacked there
well yeah but we're actually didn't push
me punching that wasn't pushy punch me
and I was actually bleeding but and I
don't know you can see in the video that
they show some that that that on the
Instagram or whatever the thing was but
he actually punch me but for me like it
don't look good for me my kids like I
I'm that's not what I'm saying yeah I
used to be fighting everywhere like
that's not what I'm about right now you
get on
I got a 12-yard or who can read and
whose all aids on the road students
I almost take a damn near college
classes in a second Barry I got another
seven-year-old that's reading on a what
sixth-grade level so they read
everything right now like and in foot
but for all the stuff I've been through
of course you know I have to tell them
like hey yo dad like Mason a couple a
lot of bad you know and this is what
they would but this is what I'm doing
them to to make sure that we okay and to
show you all like everybody can make
mistakes and come through it so I don't
want to be which it is what it is what
it is like people know my reputation
people know I'm not which [ __ ] like
I don't have to I don't have to promote
that you get I'm saying 100 that's not
what I'm promoting you get I'm saying
I'm promoting being a father everyday
you know enjoying my time with my kids
being the best dad I can be and lovely
playing football now if it gets to a
point where I have to do what I got to
do I got to do it I do you get unsigned
but yeah of course that's not what I'm
trying to promote we're we're about to
talk it a little bit about the week-one
matchup Jalen Ramsey versus Odell
Beckham and I'm curious how you think
that's going to go down oh of course
you're they don't talk about that she
gotta be I'm saying like enjoy each
other on the field but like a certain
point that's you gotta stop yeah you
know what this is like
they don't make no sense like if you
gonna keep keep doing the same thing
dumb dumb [ __ ] oh they woke you out and
got the point across the place football
right yeah yeah them both got each other
yeah who do you who do you look at right
now at the corner position in football
where you just go man that guy's the man
right now who's like the one or two
names I know there's so many good ones
and and it's hard to pick from but but
Jalen Ramsey does he top that list for
you is there anybody else there that
we're thinking about it yeah right who's
just when you watch out a fellow
Kirkpatrick he's a good player but you
gotta realize you got a hell
right now yes he no I don't know how
good he is if that front wasn't like
that but he got a hell of a front he
played hard he top will get it and um he
gotten a look he got some dogs so I did
yeah he don't do I like I like my boy
Arizona apart either Santa patty
United he's always always played good to
me
willows you put like Marcus Peters in
that class as a clarity play heart give
me a couple more name I know Jason
Barret Jason yeah I had a chance to meet
him at the Provo when we went to the
Provo it's 2015 and I like you man I
know his skills are unbelievable super
healthy yeah yeah all right I got one
who's that but he's a little bit better
player break ground I hear you it's a
very similar skill set I totally see
that a hundred percent I mean just
unbelievable I love brick brick brick
choucas he's undersized gonna they
played hard yeah unbelievable athletic
ability right yeah I can see that my
last question was going to be from the
outside looking in a lot of NFL fans
don't understand like Marvin Lewis and I
think your Sims has taught me a lot
about guys like Jeff Fisher over the
years and how and Mike Tomlin that they
relate to guys and it's it creates such
a camaraderie what is it like playing
for Marvin Lewis just for people from
the outside that will never get that
chance really try to get into in a
person of the play you know the be on
that team Marvin gonna know everything
about you and you can go certain places
where coaches only know your first name
you know and it's really just all about
Sunday but I can't say he do take his
time to interact with the clubs and I
truly think that he he care about the
players you know
it's not just all right you just need to
do this I can't say this he called me
and told me I'm good look at my workout
he's one of the first ones to call me
Friday morning before I went to work
dogs so Wow landmark unbelievable
relationship regardless if they work
here or not I always would have talked
and utmost respect for more awesome
awesome
Adam you're the man dude we can't wait
to see where you're signing him I'll
have to buy that Jersey
yeah don't we're gonna pump you up big
time when you get signed to I mean I
best of luck man keep working hard and
stay ready man I appreciate it man I'm
still the best partner turn that down
though yeah I don't worry you don't have
to worry we're gonna build pubbing you
hear any time a team needs a corner
we're gonna be going well why don't you
sign Pacman Jones and get that going
so don't worry little bit we got your
back all right brother
see man be good all right the pack man
he he's one of a kind he really is one
of a kind a whole lot of money oh he's
one of a kind I feel like he likes
knocking people out he just doesn't want
to be known for knocking people out no
like you could tell I think he kind of
liked tables but he said he used to
fight all the time
yeah I mean that's what he was and you
know now God you were with him in
Tennessee I really was never with him on
a team that's how the hell are you guys
friend because he was in Tennessee and I
was there shortly after that and I knew
some of his friends of course some of
the guys on Tennessee still came in
contact with us what was the first time
you met Pacman Jones Josh the first time
I met PAC
damn I'm trying to think even when that
first time was I do think it was down in
Tennessee somewhere I just can't
remember where we were I felt like the
reason I probably don't remember when I
first met him is because I felt like I
knew him before I met him because of
course Ted we had a lot of Texas players
on that Tennessee Titans team and they
would always tell me pack stories and I
would always be laughing at them because
they'd be like damn this remember do you
I just remember I don't even think I can
share them all but I just remember
thinking like writing stories are they
part of your stories everything right a
little of everything I want to know
I know but he was a little bit like you
know I'll say this where I always prided
myself on a guy and a lot of guys in the
NFL
like pride of the stuffing and you know
I just you know I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it that's I mean that's a theme of a
football player [ __ ] coach said morena
run through the wall [ __ ] it I'll do it
that's what I'll do
I guess what I'm paid to do [ __ ] it so
I'm sorry I'm swearing so much but
that's the thing that I got to the NFL
apologist with more in SAP where I was
like man I thought I said [ __ ] a lot
this guy's taking it a whole new level
this is like amazing I've never seen a
guy who will challenge the establishment
like this right and those are the
stories I constantly heard about pac-man
like that pac-man is extremely smart
like exploring this ran right there
about his kids yeah it was cool that's
great because he is he's he's grown up
he's matured he's really been on the
straight and narrow for the most part
for the last few years kind of is that
40 year old with dreads that you were
talking about and he's realizing too
though but you could tell how smart he
is and how he's he's realizes that
perception is important right even
though he knows he did nothing wrong in
that
some stupid team with some idiot front
office cousin at all look there's that
pac-man gentles get in trouble again
they're not gonna know that the other
guy egged him on for 10 minutes him
stepping in front of Randy Moss how many
guys in the league would watch Randy
Moss on tape and go I think I could be
the one to stop him do you think that
happened a lot yes and I do then they
were immediately reminded worries so
when I got to Tampa of course they were
still we they had just got done being
out of that division right there in that
in the NFC North anymore all those years
they were playing green bags all the
time so the stories about Randy or two
people when I got the NFL from Bucks
defensive players Barry Sanders for one
because I mean you know John Lynch and
Derrick Brooks and some of those guys
they talk about Barry Sanders and they
just be like man I was one-on-one very
Sanders embarrassed silence a few dots
oh my man John would talk about John's
really cool they'd be like man you don't
believe it was kind of cool it's like
getting crossed over my Ivers exactly
right like it's supposed to happen
yeah but then the other one was Randy
Randy was the other guy when I got there
that I always felt like I wasn't asking
these questions but he would
here in the locker room I'm like
remember that play we had a double
covered and we were like 25 yards off
woman we do no way he can run by us and
then he'd run by us like those are just
constant stories and I think that's the
number one thing I've always heard about
Randi is what he said you watch him on
film and you go he's fast but you don't
realize how fast he is because the long
strides are so deceiving and he could
cover four to five yards per stride when
he really got going yeah and that's
where I think it jumps up on people like
a pack because he goes doesn't really
look like he's come and having me that
faster than all sudden you like oh crap
he's by me yeah I don't know what
pac-man was talking though in terms of
the jail and Ramsey Odell thing I guess
well I know they talked they they've
been talking well here nothing special
right it's got me really excited here's
Jalen Ramsey talking about Odell Beckham
jr. I mean let's get this out the way
right now he's a good receiver but like
this hasn't been like an ongoing thing
this isn't this is an Adele and Josh
Norman no not at all but I am so excited
for that that game is gonna be is that
that might be of all of the matchups of
all the positions I think that's the
best matchup of the entire week one hmm
I
chi'lan Ramsey versus Odell I mean it's
gotta be pretty damn impressive to beat
that there's no question I mean that's
the to me the the elite outside freak of
nature athletes going against each other
in football right now I think Odell is
the freakiest receiver in the sport I
think Jalen Ramsey is the freakiest DB
in the sport and hey listen the I mean
then Pac Man mentioned hey yes is the
his front four it is phenomenal I get
that certainly but man Jalen Ramsey can
do things that just other corners in
football can't and it's a very rare
sized skill set I'm trying to look at
some other matchups you know that are
that could be fun there's nothing like
that nothing like that that's that's
pretty Chandler Jones versus Trent
Williams you know what I mean like it's
like what else is even gonna
you know Dwane Brown versus von Miller
no there's nothing that's going to touch
that that's the best matchup 100% who do
you that I want to get you're pretty
whoa wait wait I I that's that's one of
the best games of the opening weekend I
mean the Jaguars having to come up to
New York in that environment the Giants
fans are gonna be charged charged up
it's a new era in New York and I do
think the Giants have the the type of
mentality and roster to where they can
they can play this all you want to play
a 16-13
will do it I think they're capable of
doing that I am making an active
decision please do you're purposely
going to call your dad late to see how
much he rips us so we're gonna call it
like in like eight ten minutes okay
let's not push it too far no no but I
think it'll be more entertaining yes
yeah angry Phil is better than anything
I'm telling you
so jaylen and OH Odell that's two of our
favorite guys let's get to some more of
our favorite guys okay this came out
from Greg Doyle in Indianapolis talking
about our man
Quinton Nelson and in it there were like
six quotes I say we adopt quit Nelson as
our favorite offensive lineman in the
NFL okay let's just run with it that
first one this is from Andrew Luck quit
and Nelson has quote the broadest back
I've ever seen in my life he is like a
human cinderblock that's what it would
like just you know with like a human
cinderblock with four limbs that's what
he is Quinton Nelson had to drop 20
pounds each summer to play on his older
brothers youth team oh my god dirt
dogging is apparently what Nelson is
telling other people he wants to do to
defensive linemen this year he wants to
knock him in the dirt and show him that
he's a dog I guess so
Jack Muir Tess he's one of a kind a
great player there's a reason he went
six overall hasn't played a game but
from everything I've seen he's lived up
to it so far hasn't taken one misstep
we're done anything that's met made me
say I don't know he's the man
that's that's the most impressive thing
of all right there really other old
linemen who you know was it Jack Newhart
was what a second round pick for them
yeah for him to say that high praise
that's and we're like a few weeks in yes
one more anthony Costanzo at guard you
want one of those people that if he's
walking down the street and someone
comes up and runs at him full speed that
person is gonna get knocked out even
though he didn't know it was coming
nelson has that ability that when people
run into him they move and he does yeah
hey Quentin I'm telling you I stoked
about earlier I don't want to watch a
guard play but I'm gonna watch quit
Nelson whenever I had the chance sure I
mean I think he's gonna be a lot like
Zach Barton in Dallas you're just gonna
constantly go yeah I mean you're gonna
watch the games and you go damn oh that
was a big hole oh that was that was
Quinn Nelson he just did collapse the
left side of the defensive line he's uh
he's rarely he's a rare breed even for
that position to be that thick that
dense and then he's extremely athletic
having him watched in person and Notre
Dame all last year and then the other
thing I said in that was talked about
there the missteps things like that he's
extremely efficient he really is he's
been coached well in college he takes
the coaching he's obsessed with the game
and yes he very rarely messes up
anything technically so that to go along
with the great physical prowess is yeah
that's what makes it a mean streak he's
got a real mean streak alright so the
other guy that is sort of a staple of
our show that's not Aaron Rodgers or
Kyle Shanahan is your 70th ranked
quarterback Blake bortles hello Blake
Austin Safari and Jenkins wanted to
defend Blake bortles we always say this
when listening to a compliment
listen to the words that are said this
is what Austin Safari and Jenkins said
about people saying that Blake bortles
isn't good I really think when people
talk about that they're always talking
about you pretty much I'm sure you are
the president of this fan club or the
anti fan club quote I am pretty sure
that Blake was in my draft
and I don't know any other quarterbacks
that have won a playoff game in our
draft class he's the only one to do that
I know quarterbacks are drafted win
Super Bowls and when playoff games win
big games and he's done that he's made
that progression I think that perception
is wrong needs to change because it
takes time what year are we in five he
is going to do what it takes to win and
that's what you want in a quarterback a
guy that wants to win and does the job
every single day if he messes up he's
gonna go out there and sling it again
not timid at all that's what I want a
quarterback that is what we need in a
quarterback there's nothing else they
can really say I guess you're right it
is the worst complemented player the
awesome because he's he's lost her skies
Mark Sanchez went to two AFC
championship games it was somewhat
similar it was all defense and he kind
of ran the offense and did what he
needed to do and when he would defend
him you'd go you know what he's winning
games he's just in the trenches with us
Sanchez was better than bike boy that's
scarier than close a scary thing I I
know I know
see what people are missing with the
Jacksonville conversation is that I
really think a good job holding yourself
back from commenting you're very good
you're so coachable then what people are
missing about the Jacksonville
conversation in my opinion is really it
just comes down to this I think you
could take like the top 20 quarterbacks
in football and if you put them on the
Jacksonville Jaguars they're at the very
least going to the AFC Championship game
if not winning the Super Ball if you
take the top ten quarterbacks and throw
them on that team that they might not
lose games this year they'd be go move
they could go 15 and 1 or 16 or no
Jacksonville's defense is the best
defense I have ever seen since the
Eagles I mean I think it's better than
the ball a d1 Eagles yeah I really do I
think it's up in that conversation do
you think it's better than the 2000
Ravens I think it's better than the Oh
two bucks you think it's better than the
thirteen Seahawks yes it gets right in
that conversation I do night they're
gonna need the Super Bowl to set the
stamp right that's it always is is 91
Eagles was so good they didn't
not either and you're right and then the
Bucks defense really was so good in that
little era to where I'm not sure if they
needed it either because they were like
the number one defense for like five
years in a row
but yes that will give it finally that
mark in history but yes if you went
through the team roster through roster
and you go yeah I'm putting that
Jacksonville defensive line on the same
team it's one of the best I've ever seen
the linebackers behind it
I mean Myles Jack after what I saw
towards the end of the last year Myles
jack is gonna be in the defensive MVP
conversation he'd be guy I'd say watch
out for it the way he ended the year his
confidence level the things they asked
him to do in New England I mean no
linebacker in football is asked to do
what Myles Jack had to do in New England
and you believe that Jalen Ramsey and AJ
booyah is the best duo exactly I want to
scare everyone the NFL yeah every
starter on the Jacksonville defense is
under contract through 2020 it's amazing
we're all gonna talk about the Vikings
and how they're getting their core
together yeah the entire Jacksonville
starting defense is signed through 2020
it's amazing I know they're scary man
they're really really scary and they're
my favorite team to watch even though I
know everybody thinks I hate Blake
bortles but their physicality and their
talent level is a notch up from every
other team in football mmm and they got
better this offseason I mean they got
better that's awesome all right let's
call Phil we've made him wait enough
let's do it do you that question no it's
gonna I was well levy on Bell was in a
strip club and I was wondering if Phil
mad don't ask Phil that one we can do
better I don't know how about the levian
thing you didn't say you know I didn't I
haven't seen it yet I doesn't girlfriend
you ever been with your wife to a strip
club yeah Wow I don't deliberately
wanted to call you five minutes late we
were ready to call you but he thought
angry phil simms is better than normal
Phil I'm really calm today God you know
how you know you have all these little
chores in life to do well I got up this
more
I did most of those chores so I'm
relaxed and calm what was your -
breakfast is r3u de CBS little lady I
think you know what I was gonna say Yeah
right no I don't know maybe something
you idiots are gonna say there's gonna
get me fired up I don't know what we're
we're going yeah I asked you where we go
talk about today and tomorrow I don't
know okay this is it's what I call great
preparation and this is why this show is
such a success
exactly exactly Phil this is the reason
is I have a belief that the sims family
is better without preparation
you're not actors even though I see you
in banking commercials all the time you
guys naturally have great intuition so I
want to embrace that first thing we're
gonna do you know you talk about yeah
new commercials whatever okay now if we
could really do those commercials the
way boomer and I shoot some of them they
would be I mean they're hilarious
you know the things he says to me is
we're walking across there to do it and
I've told you this one time we were
shooting a commercial and every time we
had to go up we had to shake each
other's hands yeah we should gives in
his hands he would say something like
you know we couldn't even get a word out
you know he go you bet you know whatever
fill in the blank and I said you're such
an a-hole and whatever and everybody's
laughing and we just saw man come on and
finally our agent Steve Rosner had to
come out and go hey guys come on
there the ad agencies starting to get
upset you know you guys got to settle
down I said really okay Wow okay
but so you can imagine how those
commercials would come out if boomer and
I had a finalization of everything they
would be cool but they're pretty cool
anyway somebody said yes to me to me
yesterday is that you on that picture
that I see you know the big billboard
and I go well I don't know what do you
think you're looking at me right now I
think it is okay all right so what's
going on so what we got here Adam give
me something today we are gonna start
off
with an absolute doozy I know the Sims
family you're both gonna go woohoo okay
you ready okay
it was ago I want you to rank which is
the best football player of the guys
going in the Hall of Fame on Saturday oh
my gosh told you I knew you're both
gonna react like that well you go pro
you know what I let them read the
language you got a name for me
I know right Randy Moss tio Brian
Dawkins Ray Lewis Brian Urlacher Jerry
Kramer Bobbie Beth Oh No
and Robert Brazil okay so I never saw
Brazil did you face him at all was uh I
probably did when he was down in Houston
which was linebackers yeah yeah you know
that was what Houston had the defense
and an offense that had like 14 all pros
but they couldn't lie on game yeah that
was a Warren Moon they were incredible
incredible and I mean and they were we
went down and played them once and all
we heard Jerry Glanville was telling one
of our coaches before the game hey our
defense is all this and they were they
were stacked and but all they did was
just blitz so you just drop back and you
go to get hit but just keep walking it
long and soon or late it won for a
touchdown right and I'm walking in at
halftime we're really beating them
pretty bad I thought we'd struggle to
beat them and I looked up the scoreboard
I mean it has total yards and I forgot
what we had I thought damn we're gonna
sit at FL record here today if this
keeps up but of course as usual we quit
throwing after that t/o Brian Dawkins
Urlacher Ray Lewis Ray Lewis
Robert Brazil and Jerry Kramer yeah all
right I know mine right away if you want
me to lead off all right how about we do
this you're each gonna give me your
number one so with the number one Chris
Simms goes with I'm gonna go with Ray
Lewis Wow Chris goes with Ray Lewis Phil
who is your know
one that's tough I'm ago Randy Moss so I
love that your difference all right give
me your why Ray Lewis over Randy Moss
and Phil why uh Moss over Lewis okay I
just go with I say Ray Lewis Ray Lewis I
think we could argue is the best
defensive player of our generation or
maybe even of since I've been alive I
know there's guys like Reggie White and
Lawrence Taylor and stuff like that in
the conversation but I do think not only
along with being maybe the one of the
greatest defensive players of my
lifetime I do think he's the greatest
middle linebacker ever and that's where
I would just go I don't know if it's
really I know there's other good ones
but I think in anybody's all time middle
linebacker list Ray Lewis would be one
two or three for sure for me he's number
one won two Super Bowls as an MVP a one
pretty damn good leader even though hail
them too many speeches for me at times
but still a pretty good damn leader so
Phil why Randy Moss over Ray Lewis Oh
after hearing Christopher I can I have
change
very good argument I don't know the
first thing that hit me and you guys
know this of course Randy Moss the
talent if his good years were
unbelievable he won games you know and I
know Ray Lewis was look I understand and
I saw a lot and he your team your
defense to me when you talk about
defense you start almost with the middle
linebacker you need a great middle
linebacker with speed to really have an
outstanding defense right and when he
first came to the league you know his
instincts are beyond approach when you
talk about Ray Lewis smarts and just
diagnosing but that's why with him and
Ed Reed my gosh those two together that
was the greatest hand I'm in the NFL
there but but I think about rainey moss
I think of all the plays how he affected
games just so much you know about how
you had to plan your defense now I don't
know on offense if you ever had to plan
your what you were going to do around
Ray Lewis
point you know something that's my
driving point and Christopher you know
this you know I never I talked about
every player in the league when I
announced for so many years I never
talked to Randy Moss and because he just
wouldn't do it
yeah and and I remember what what do you
mean because he was an urban legend like
I said he would buck the establishment
because he was so good he so soon he
never came in and spoke to you Phil no
no but I don't I don't feel slighted cuz
I don't think he did with anybody no
right but we're in England doing a game
the Ravens are there and no it's the
paid search I mean and Randy Moss is on
the side of the field and Jim Nantz says
you know I'm gonna go over and talk to
Randy and I said I just said there's
good luck with that
laughs and Jim walks over there and he
gets with it about eight feet of him and
he's getting ready to walk up behind and
he hears him say a few things and Jim
just turns around and walks back I said
what happened to that conversation and
he goes well I can't I can't even begin
to repeat he goes what Randy Moss said
he goes I think I'd better leave this
situation here it's just such a smart
player my son knows that he has with him
and you know his credibility and Swagger
whatever you want to talk about his the
smartest in the locker room was just as
big as Ray Louis's yeah and all you got
to do what really sealed it for me was
when he was with the Patriots what he
did but that football team to help them
go you know 18 and know and all that but
what he did to the locker room because
he's one of those players and I we
thought maybe we talked about this one
well you you said no but you say you
know it's funny as you said this to me
of like a week ago just a little bit
like you said that Belichick
acknowledged his greatness in the locker
room right because yeah how many players
like I remember baby did this Michael
Vick Randy Moss he's trying to think of
guys ray lose the whole league all the
players the black players they looked up
to him because they were just the man
right and they because they loved the
way they acted what they did and of
course you had to have great talent I'm
missing somebody we've talked about but
before Christopher yes I know we're
missing somebody I'm talking about guys
who those two that didn't have to bow to
the establishment basically what
happened with Bella check in moss what
was their relationship it was great
yeah wasn't good it was great and it
just and that's where it's down to money
but you know that's the other thing that
happens and in New England you know look
when money is an issue with the football
team you know they don't let emotions
get in the way they're they does okay we
got to move on because we can't afford
all these guys all right so this Deon
would probably be the other guy you were
thinking about me alone yes I mean
they're the kings and they're still hey
they're still looked upon and Michael
Vick walked across the stage he's like
Lawrence Taylor but I don't know if the
players looked up to Loras like this
wherever he goes I mean you know people
they'll go crazy because of he was the
first really electrifying running
quarterback of course he happened he was
black and I just man I just had changed
the view of a lot of people and he's
still thought about I think on that same
way yes
number two Chris who's your number two I
mean he made a great argue I'm going
Randy Moss number zero mosk yeah Phil
who are you going number two all right
so there's more there we know that all
right Chris who is your number three my
number three is going to be Terrell
Owens give the reason Mahalo
what's here Phil so Phil who's yours oh
and yet you still have Brian Dawkins
Urlacher I you know Jerry Kramer and
Brazil I'm kind of are living let's take
them out because they're not the modern
you're not yeah we can't all right so
it's Owens or lacquer and Dawkins for
your number three Phil oh all right so
Chris why don't you start off the tío
waxing why he's number three well tio
I would argue is the third greatest
receiver in the history of the sport
only behind Jerry Rice and Randy Moss he
is you know a lot like what dad said
he's the second guy to come along there
he said men receivers can be this big in
this fast and this quick I mean Randy
was really the first guy so he was a
trendsetter tio was the next guy
and you know a lot of the things like
dad said about R and eto was a guy that
your defense change game plans and he
had to play T Oh especially in his prime
and even in the area where I'd look at
him and go you know he has one advantage
over it over even a Randy Moss who I
think is slightly better than them
career wise teo was more of a danger
throughout of his career to catch the
six yard slant or the six yard hitch and
run seventy yards with it after the
catch Terrell Owens is the third
greatest receiver I've ever seen in my
life in person on TV whatever it may be
he's a physical specimen that was even
rare for the freakiest of guys and
that's why I put him three Phil what's
your best teo memory oh well I don't
know you wrote in the card out of course
it's all the stuff you know the popcorn
the cheerleader pom-poms it's whatever
it is all that look that's that's why
you know many that's just one one
example of why he wasn't her first
ballot hall-of-famer so but he'll all
the things that Christopher said how
physical take the short passes score
with them and and you know yeah he
didn't get along with teams and guys
because it had to be about him and I was
thinking about this the other day cuz
I'm sure we're gonna talk about this
when the season starts and I go well
alright let him be the star okay it's
about you who cares you know I I always
think about great coaches would he'd
have been this guy if he went to New
England right would he be that guy he
had Bill Parcells we need have been that
guy he had Jimmie Johnson I mean guys
that were control freaks but they seem
to be able to get along and make it work
with every player they had around them
who was a bigger pain in the butt than
Keyshawn Johnson and then who goes there
Bill Parcells who is the guy sitting
next to Bill Parcells every mood him
he's like a shadow that's right Sean
yeah that's right he just knew how to
get to these guys and so if I was a
quarterback I would take a back seat you
know it's easy to say now since I'm not
playing
but going man you know I'm gonna do
whatever it takes to keep my man happy
because my man is the man
right we said what was this car ride
with t oh what's that back i said you
wrote in the car with them back in the
day right you'd written in his big G
wagon or whatever when he first had it
remember that yeah yeah I can barely
remember that you bring that up nice
like God I probably forgot that you know
leave these things happen to you son as
you get older forget some things that
went on in your life but I know we
talked about this but it's a shame he
went didn't go first first ballot Hall
of Fame and I know people disagree with
me and all the Hall of Famers are upset
but I'm not yeah you're not Phil gets it
he's been he's been on the T outside
although the time he told me because it
should be in the [ __ ] Hall of Fame no
no people always said to me that's great
thank you for saying that at them but
it's just not true it's just not true
hold on a second Super Bowl then I guess
that's the thing they put you in the
Hall of Fame if you wouldn't got hurt
then that one no okay that's that's
really interesting but no the numbers no
you know the only thing I'm mad I mean
25 years of calling the game Phil might
be enough and then when you add a Super
Bowl in fact you played for Belichick
and parcels and pretty much like started
this whole thing and and was throwing
for yardage that was unseen beforehand I
mean come on there's enough there hey
look big guy all these times we talked
at them and you know and I love this in
the media I'm not a humble guy right no
no you like to let people know okay so I
don't deserve to be in it it really is
but you know on that hand yeah I think
there are a lot of guys they don't
deserve to be in there yes I mean a lot
right and that you know that drives me
all we want more guys to get in there
why at any but we can't let tío in until
the third time or whatever it was a
third try yeah but there's a lot of guys
that don't deserve to be in there and
just how the whole thing works
look it should be X players general
managers personnel people players
whatever it is putting these guys in the
Hall of Fame that's who should be doing
it but you know that my argument isn't
that I'm repeating myself probably I
want to be a voter for the
Pro Football Hall of Fame writers I'll
tell you who was a writer deserves of me
in there and who shouldn't be all right
give me one writer that should be in the
Hall of Fame well I can't name you know
but I know I know what you mean all
right oh let's get people that really
have nothing to do with the game to be
the people decide who goes in the Hall
of Fame yeah all right so writers I
appreciate what they do but you know
they can only there's so many answers
they go by score stats this that they
really don't can't and rightly so what
being can really pay attention enough to
really know I think one of my biggest
gripes about the Hall of Fame is some
defensive players and especially
offensive linemen who are Hall of Famers
they don't get in right that is my
number one yeah it's be [ __ ] like a
guy like Allen Faneca or some of those
guys you just go in with the greatest
guards we've ever seen in the game
they're still not in because they
mentioned you know oh oh oh you know how
many touchdowns any kids yeah right you
[ __ ] and you know hey Charles Haley
yeah played against some great guys
Reggie White right I mean this it's on
and on just all the great defensive bit
players that we play - yeah and Charles
Haley man if he's not one he said he's
up there one two or whatever what the
best that we ever played against yeah
right as a Giants and you know again you
know I've always said this Richard dent
well that great Bears defense knows we
talked about Richard did a lot yeah
right I mean that's that's all I
remember hearing aid you know blocking
anybody go or block does dead guy yeah
you know right shoulder you're gonna go
out before you go out check out dead
make sure he's not gonna kill Sims
before he throws the ball alright so
this is the most important one who was a
better overall player Brian Dawkins or
Brian Urlacher Dawkins is gonna be my
fourth guy okay and I'll just I'll start
a dad and what's what's Phil picking
okay Phil are you picking Urlacher or
Dawkins I'm picking talkin yes
so I mean yes for me Dawkins is the best
safety knot named Troy Polamalu and Edie
read that we've seen in this generation
and I do think he's in that conversation
with them - he just
he was unfortunate that he didn't get to
win Super Bowls and be in some of those
big games that they did all the time I
think he'd be more of a household name
right Dawkins is phenomenal played on
great defenses could do it do it all
ultimate professional I played with him
in Denver he's amazing and then I'll
just go to Urlacher five and just say
this Urlacher to me is the one guy that
does not belong in this class I'm sorry
right and I'm not trying to take a knock
on Brian Urlacher I really like him and
I think he's Hall of Fame material but
the fact that he got in a first-ballot
Hall of Fame along with Ray Lewis I
think is totally wrong Urlacher like I
said as a Hall of Famer Bret
first-ballot Hall of Famers are only
four people in my mind like Randy Moss
Ray Lewis Joe Montana Tom Brady the
all-time greats of the all-time greats
and that's where I think they're wrong
on Urlacher yeah that's a good opinion
you know you talk about Brian Dawkins
you know Adam he was not troy polamalu
but he wasn't far behind it
they got to play in an era where
safeties were like really big in the
game right and because that's when they
could hit and do whatever so it puts him
in the right there with ronnie Lott you
know hey look ronnie Lott might not have
been the fastest safety in the world or
corner whatever but the one thing you
knew he was smart he could read what you
were doing and if somebody caught
something over the middle he was gonna
you know he was gonna knock him out
right and you know and Brian Dawkins was
in that same mold his speed you know he
was almost built you know almost like
Choi Polamalu
yeah and he was great he was great he's
a first-ballot hall-of-famer and and one
of the best safeties I've ever watched
and you see he changed things so in
other words if you're a receiver and a
quarterback you have to be leery of
where he's at what we're doing and no
one if you throw certain passes you're
putting one of your buddies or teammates
in a little bit of danger right because
he's coming the other way right Phil
you're the man dude do you have fun yeah
it was good that's pretty good
conversation I liked it you'll always
say this I need
right something's down so when I season
starts I kind of see it again because
he'll I probably forget before the
season starts Phil are you ever gonna
write a book yes I am are you really
oh I am yeah I'm all right I'm a dime
I'll have some fun doing this book yes I
am if you need a ghostwriter I could
figure out how to write and then I'll
write your book you know what I really
want to do and I'm not me a mean I'm not
but you know it's just you know I
watched all the TV shows which I'll do
this morning again have to watch my son
holy Christ I go he goes elated to me
when he said that we'll get into that
later but just to have us just sit back
have a show and just go over everything
that was said that day in this go listen
to what this guy said yes crazy right I
know it's crazy
I know it I just you know I don't know
why I get upset I tell boomer these
things and boomer goes man just relax
you know they're just you know don't
worry about it I go you know what boomer
I can't help but I do worry about it and
here's why I worry about and it bothers
me because we're talking about players
their lives their families and
everything else is involved because
they're all in there and you're talking
and you don't know what you're talking
about and it really really bothers me
yeah well that's why people listen to
the sims left go podcast Phil what's
that that's why they listen to the Sims
and left go podcast yeah we get after
that crap we don't know you know what
you know I always hey I hear was a great
question everybody used to tell me or
asked me when I was in the broadcasting
do you think you can tell the truth
about you know and I said hey yeah I'm
gonna tell the truth
almost straighten a bunch of crap out
too right
you know I can't tell you how many times
are going to do a game and you know if
just like I remember with Greg Gumbel we
were doing a game once I think we were
going down to Miami and he goes all man
and so on so played really bad and this
and that I said you know Greg let's do
this so back then we'd go into the
team's a room and we'd watch film right
and so we ended up watch the film and
Greg goes and I'm talking the whole time
he goes cut it's unbelievable
because he really played pretty well but
we
steam on TV yeah and I said yeah that's
why TV lies and you know there's so many
things it's not only the person talking
about it but it's how you shoot the game
and how you present it yes and you know
it was really a great experience and he
always went in and watched film with me
so we could tell what we thought at
least was that as closest to the truth
as we could get the research we did
right awesome
Phil you're the man dude you the man dad
you guys are great and I'll talk to you
next week
all right so you died I don't even to
pay him anymore he just comes on next
week I want to say I had always hoped
that Brian Dawkins was going to get to
the Hall of Fame but I'm gonna be honest
and tell you that I didn't think it was
gonna happen you didn't think it would
no yeah because I think for the longest
time like I'm still getting over the
fact of the Eagles won the Super Bowl
yeah let alone the fact that Brian
Dawkins is getting into the Hall of Fame
in the same calendar year yeah because
for me there was an era of Eagles
football that I didn't think was going
to end
so buddy Ryan ends in the early 90s rich
coat tight camp comes in and we know
what that was
yeah railroads we thought was going to
be the answer he wins coach of the year
then it kind of fades off right and
right at the end of railroads is when
Brian Dawkins was drafted 98
second-round pick out of Clemson and
that's the thing about Brian Dawkins to
me is he assured in Eagles fans actually
winning and for that entire 90s decade
any time we thought we had a chance up
you got to play on the road with Rodney
Peete in Dallas it wasn't gonna happen
right and then so for me being an Eagles
fan
I didn't associate winning football
games with the Eagles I associated I'm
gonna wait until they're losing so that
me and my dad can go outside and have a
catch right Brian Dawkins comes in and
is this creation of Jim Johnson in this
laboratory of a hybrid safety hybrid
Corner hybrid linebacker that could also
rush the
hasser he's the only guy in the history
of the NFL with more than 25
interceptions more than 25 forced
fumbles more than 25 sacks he was just a
game changer every time he played and it
was the first guy that when I would talk
about my team to other NFL fans they'd
go but I like that Brian Dawkins yeah
sure no one else out Troy Vincent he's
not that good Bobby Taylor he's a little
too slow
Jeremiah Trotter he's a little fat too
uh Donna McNabb yeah
but Brian talk nobody argued that was
the first guy that people said I wish he
was on my team yeah this is a guy that I
loved since 1998 right like I'm not
joking when I say he was my AI m
screenname my screen name was doc for
MVP he's still 90% of my passwords so we
need to get him on the podcast is but
your gentleman hate him I've never I've
never had his number I've never had a
guy like this is a guy that I'm worried
yeah I watched suplex Lavernia skulls
I watched him take the soul of Ike
Hilliard
I watched him remove all of the bones
out of algae Crumpler body this is a guy
that in the biggest games yeah took a
life yes
like he removed people and then when the
Eagles finally got through all of those
NFC Championship losses the Rams won we
didn't expect the Bucs won that felt
like a knife in the back the Panthers
that was absolutely humiliating with
Ricky Manning's three interceptions when
we finally get through the Falcons and
he destroys algae Crumpler and Terry
Bradshaw gives him the microphone after
the championship game and he goes into
that Weapon X character and he's like I
I've never I felt like I was outside of
my body and it's funny because all of my
friends would really say Adam you're an
Eagles fan but you're really a Brian
Dawkins fan yeah I'll never forget I'm
in Kentucky and I'm covering a high
school football game and I'm shooting
this is Trinity football baby they never
lost and I'm down at one side I'm
shooting a touchdown and I hear and now
on the other side
the field he's the only player in one
game to return a punt for a touchdown
MoMA and it's this I remember the game
Houston Texans they were favored by 21
it was the largest spread in Eagles
history and they covered it because
Brian Dawkins scored like 4 different
ways and I'm listening and I go that's
Brian Dawkins and I looked down the
field and I see a guy and I go it's him
he's here
I have a third cat his nephew played on
the team he was a running back that went
to Purdue I'm carrying a 30-pound camera
and I'm sprinting down the sidelines
remember there's like 90 guys in a high
school football team and they're all
there on the sidelines I'm jumping over
one guy I dumped and dodged another guy
I stiff-armed a child like the kid was
14 and I put my hand right in his chest
plate and pushed him off and I get down
there and I get a shot of my run up to
him and I grab and this is right after
he went to Denver and that was really
hard for me yeah because that was Andy
Reid leaving that was we're not gonna
give him the money
Denver's gonna overpay for him and I
hugged him and he he's in Kentucky who's
an Eagles fan in Kentucky yeah and I hug
him and I look him in the face and I
didn't even say I love you I didn't even
I said two things one you're all of my
passwords and he looked at me like I was
crazy and then I said please don't tell
me you wanted to leave and he looked at
me and he said I never wanted to leave
Philadelphia yeah and in that moment I
almost [ __ ] cried I'm almost gonna
[ __ ] cry now you were because it's
big upper-lip time let go Brian Dawkins
to me is how I always wanted to play if
I could yeah complete reckless abandon
from the way he entered a game to the
way that he played the game to the way
that players talked about him after the
game Brian Dawkins was in my mind the
perfect football player and he played on
my imperfect Philadelphia Eagles yeah
and for him to get in the same year they
finally won a Super Bowl pretty amazing
this to me is like the culmination of my
fan hood and he works for them and got a
ring it's amazing Brian Dawkins god
bless you
I will still think that you're the in my
list he's the best guy going in this
year he's over moss he's over 8 Lewis vo
Santi Elias weekend I'm a hundred
percent biased Brian Dawkins I love you
you're the [ __ ] man
congratulations on the Hall of Fame
yours I know I know I'm not talking to
all you know it's camera I'm looking at
right now this is just awesome yeah
super dope everybody out there if you
wanted like so how's your upper lip okay
I don't think I got that no I didn't get
that
I didn't write anything down that was a
notice this is so well enough go gets
emotional and he's got fight back tears
if you ever want to just watch the video
I loved and watched left goes upper lip
it grows it's like unbelievable it can
go like three times bigger once he gets
because I'm trying to hold it it you're
really funny so you've done this to me
numerous times yeah it's like when we
went out with all the bigwigs in this
office
took us out to eat and all of a sudden
they started bringing us like food and
drinks and we're like we didn't pay for
this Hey and and one guy that was there
was like oh no I think this is for me
and the waiter was like no actually the
chef is actually an Eagles fan and he
wants to celebrate the Super Bowl with
Adam everyone's like oh well Adam and I
couldn't even enjoy that moment for a
second cuz Sims comes over the top and
goes this never [ __ ] happens to him
this is [ __ ] don't think he's
important he's a [ __ ] I appreciate you
very much you're such a nice guy I am
thank you
that's great working with you [ __ ] you
alright so we got to our favorite guys
Stefon Diggs got [ __ ] paid let's talk
about Stefon Diggs really quick yes it's
getting 70 million 71 million guaranteed
coming out to around 14 a year and the
first thing that I thought was Stefon
Diggs was did he just take Anthony bars
money and I would have given that money
to Anthony bar
I love Stefan days yeah we've had him on
the show now once or twice really good
guy I think he's it's special what he
did against New Orleans Saints the fact
that they drafted him in the fifth round
he loves that team he's a very talented
receiver yeah but I think Anthony bar is
better at his position than digs in his
position
yeah and they it seems like Minnesota's
locked up all of the
future guys and I don't know if bars in
it anymore yeah I don't know either
that'll be it'll be very interesting to
see going forward I mean first of all
Rick's feelings done a great job I was
staying ahead of the curve right getting
guys a little bit before they get to the
market getting them for the low saving a
few million dollars on every contract
the bar thing I think will be
interesting I think if you made me bet
I'm gonna say Anthony bars and not gonna
be I'm gonna sort of Viking after this
year that's just because I know they
gave Eric Kendricks money he's making
ten million dollars a year at that
position and I think Anthony bars gonna
look at it and go I think I'm worth that
at the very least in America is so right
there a little bit there different
exactly right but I think in a
modern-day NFL that I would rather have
bar because of what has his length and
speed and the pass game is special so
any her tearing rug that's gonna that's
gonna be interesting to see going
forward I think the thing I look at it
like this to again you said all the
things about Stefon Diggs like no doubt
about it
but he's not in the Julio Jones Odell
Antonio Brown Stratos is making more
than Julio Jones this year even after
whenever he got away
right no he's not in Keenan Allen is not
dehydrate Hopkins yes this is one of the
worst I think this is one of the most
occasionally walk-ins
I'm taking Sammy Watkins to this hammer
Adam feeling Wow
who's the number one on their team can
we say before this becomes a thing
Stefon Diggs we love you we do good dad
congratulations
we're generational thank you let's make
sure but we're just saying I'm just
saying it Diggs is awesome and I would
want Diggs on my football team because
he asked no weakness and he does
everything good but I don't look at
anything in this game and go oh that's
great and I would say really the number
one receiver on their football team
scheme last year was Thielen I mean the
alum deal had 91 catches for twelve
hundred and seventy six yards Stefon
Diggs had 64 for 849 he's never had a
thousand yards receiving in the season
he's never had a hundred catches no and
again Stephon we're not taking any shots
at you it's more like your agents a boss
yeah your agent was awesome it's a box
peel man and I think
the rest of the Vikings community got in
love with the fact that he was their GM
listener late yet their late round gem
right they're always in doubt because
it's more proof that you're a good GM
right now she took a look at my fifth
rounder yeah he's one of the 10 best
receivers in football now because I paid
him like that no you you paid him like
that and you shouldn't have I and then
yes the Minnesota miracle exactly right
those two things I think added to these
extra dollars but yes I mean Stefon
Diggs he's like 10 11 million a year guy
I know that's what I guessed at him to
be I said he would get 11 million that's
was one of my skills right right that's
like Doug Baldwin category which is like
what he is and I don't think he's as
good as Doug ball I don't think so
either
right and Doug Wallens making 11.5
million the feeling thing though is
pretty that's a pretty that hits you
right in the gut what it does that's
when you go damn okay yeah all right I
mean feeling special so what are they
gonna do I mean Theon's gotta be looking
at and going wait wasn't I the one that
when we needed a big play in the past
came they were going to me last year
yeah so he's gonna want more money here
too but yeah I just think it's over
paying him a little bit I'm not gonna
anchor for Stefon Diggs that he got it
but yeah I don't think he's in the AJ
Green Julio Jones class all right
speaking of people that and that
speaking of contracts
Le'Veon Bell Tomlin kind of said
something about him that was interesting
yeah he said I'm hopeful that I'll be in
better condition even than when he was a
year ago when he came in right strong
belief in the Steelers organization that
really those first three weeks of the
year he had one rushing touchdown
average 260 yards a game and I think a
lot of people thought he wasn't really
working out during that time right video
has come out of him and his girlfriend
at a strip club and it's circling on
social media he also has a new rap album
coming out on Friday I again we're
always on the side of the players here
we are the players podcast I think this
is a fair way of Tomlin trying to get it
out in the media though though kind of
being like please come in and shape once
we do need you yes and then and I get
that I mean yeah levy on bail I'm just
gonna go through I was waiting for the
outrage after the strip club video you
shouldn't be there you should be a
practice you should be working on your
and there's a lot of people in the NFL
that we're gonna be saying that about if
that's the case yeah because you got a
night I mean we'll get into that a
second first of all but we of dammit I
messed this up gosh damn it stupid thing
I messed it up hold on one second so 32
yards the first game I have a point here
that I'm going to get to okay 32 yards
the first game second game okay here we
go it's the Minnesota Vikings pretty
good defense 27 rushes for 87 yards
still nothing special but but but I
understand it okay and then we got week
three I think it's the Chicago Bear game
member they lose that game that was like
oh man there what's going on he had 15
carries for 61 yards now you and I
recognized at the time that he did not
have the pop and his like my point would
be for this all for for what Mike Tomlin
said I don't think you can get in shape
at that position unless you just play
the position that's the problem
there's no way to only jam and running
it's great the ball tucked into your
chest and you kind of kind of be running
through people yeah you got to be
running through people you got to be
have a heart rate of going oh my gosh
everybody's trying to kill me I just
killed this guy I ran over them fought
for extra yards I pulled a sled you know
for 15 yards and then I got in a huddle
and 30 seconds later I had to do it
again that's like you can't do that you
can't get ready for the emotions the
intensity of that position I don't care
what he does he could be in phenomenal
shape that's what you always hear
football shape right football shape yeah
that's what they're talking about
because you can be hey I'm great at
running gassers and I'm in great shape
but the intensity of the sport and when
you're out there cannot be matched than
any workout yeah I mean I'm sorry your
intensity level goes up a little higher
when you're alright I've been blocking a
bag all week and then all sudden vantes
Burfict coming in on full speeds not a
bag exactly so now you're expending way
more energy than you can even plan for
us so that would be the first thing I'd
say it's okay yes strip club strip club
so NFL players going to Strickland lot
of blood out of bail players going to
strip clubs they're not going on there
they're not going there days they have
to get up early in the morning and do
things like that but as you know first
thing I'll say I my recollection is
young people who have a lot of money in
their pocket they go to the strip clubs
a lot
so before we start judging everybody in
the world and I know a whole hearted was
going to sure clubs all that that's me I
got a lot of 45 year old friends who
work on Wall Street they gonna strip
club a few times every week because they
got to entertain their clients that
that's okay we don't have to judge them
but Le'Veon Bell okay yes he went to the
scribbler brought his girlfriend okay
cool I like that I've never done that
I've done that my I brought my wife
before have some fun yeah I'm sure
there's great time but NFL players this
isn't part of the culture to a degree
certainly you got young guys with money
in their pocket and if you have a night
off especially in training camp to like
when we were in Tampa we had training
camp in Orlando if we had a night with
no curfew or a night where we didn't
have to get up early the next morning
there was definitely gonna be a handful
of guys I went to the strip club me
included I'm not even gonna lie I mean
there was times in Tampa when I was the
starting quarterback and you were gonna
see me walk in the dollhouse at some
point you should get recognized yeah but
it was like but the dot is so also over
the announcer be like come up a little
stage oh look who just walked in the
door it's Chris Sam's trying to go back
for your tip of a box specials that's
good that was very good because that's
actually what the guy sounded like but
but yeah we would go there I would go
there Christopher and I would have to
explain to my girlfriend or my wife
Danielle either way at the time you know
she wasn't always thrilled than me going
there but I'd be like you know the
dollhouse they serve great steaks they
got TVs everywhere I would never
understood that yeah but people talk
about but as much she could be there so
I'd have to go you know I was like okay
where are we meeting tonight guys are
gonna have a Thursday night dinner or
Friday night dinner where we go and they
bake oh we're at the doll house so we're
you know at shangri-la or whatever they
were look at your wife like sorry it's a
team tough one there yes but yes four
young guys who have money in their
pocket and have freedom like that you
know yes that's what happens with in
America or whether you're in Tokyo well
yeah yeah it's my my favorite strip
clubs story so I'm going to tell this I
guess is uh my so say you've tried to
tell those story two or three times I
think four times never made the pod
never made the pocket yes
is a historic moment in the podcast
history if you can land it if I can let
it not josh is in our ear if he can land
it it's very hard for me because I
always go overboard and say something
too crude to where they cut it off the
podcast I'm not gonna do this here is
this your first preseason first precis
after the bucks with a Super Bowl box
when the Super Bowls are playing the
Jets in Japan Tokyo and Tokyo which is
unbelievable I can't believe they did
that I can't believe it either it's a
pain in the ass and it really it really
screwed up our season it really did
they're trying to make it global all
those Japanese kids play in the NFL now
it really paid off trying to make it two
years later and and let alone it's not
like we're there for a week you're there
it's a 12 hour time difference and we
were there for like I'm gonna say 60
hours I never I never asked you this was
brooding and complaining about it the
entire time I know is he liking it no I
think there was complaints leading up to
it and even in OTAs like all we got to
do this we got an extra breeze using you
know like we need this we have the
shortest offseason we've won the Super
Bowl now we got to do this
so I think there was complaints like
that but once you get to that time of
the year the coaches never show any like
it's go forward and are tunnel vision
and we're focused so they never let up
on that but so yes we have a night out
where we're gonna meet the Jets at some
like little cocktail hour - three nights
before I think it's two nights before
the game and that night we have freedom
we have no meetings nothing so we're
gonna get out on the town and we're
rookies they're like it's me and the
guys and you guys cool and I'm gonna
follow Dwight Smith wherever he goes
that's my god Dwight's my homey and he's
gonna leave me in the right direction so
it's Dwight where we going man he goes
we're gonna go down to Roppongi and I'm
like what
it's Roppongi okay Roppongi is where all
the cool bars and cool spots are oh
that's an area of Tokyo area of Tokyo
that was the name of the club yes so
it's a Roppongi area so now now you
remember the name is Club now he goes
hey I think we're gonna go meet SAP over
at one-eyed Jack and I'm like one-eyed
Jack what sounds like a hole in the wall
pretty much and he goes it's supposed to
be some strip club so I go okay I mean
I'm kind of like gosh I don't really
feel like doing the strip club thing
let's just stay out and bars and just
girls that way we go to one-eyed Jack
and it's an obscure jar obscured or
hole-in-the-wall kind of like you're
saying and I'm like man this kind of
looks crap give me the visual you walk
up to the door and what does it look
it's like like just a normal like black
door
that's like ders I can't see in the room
or nothing it's just a stairwell behind
it so I'm like man it just doesn't look
jazz that looks nothing I'm just
thinking this is like some crap place
that some of the guys on the team found
and for some reason we're going here
before Yelp so I get my ID they look and
okay we're going in I go in and right
away the bright lights come on I start
to go whoa this place might be big time
because there's pictures of every famous
person you can think of on the wall as
we're walking down the stairs and I mean
everybody actors athletes whatever it
like the biggest actors I guess like I'm
just trying to out anybody but yeah I
wish it I know but
as big as it gets like you're just like
damn that guy's what an Oscar and
there's people that if you said one name
they would know that's right it's that
kind of guys we're just like holy cow so
we walk into this place and I'm not
expecting much like I said but I walk in
and it's amazing I mean amazing not only
just because the girls were beautiful
and I'm not gonna try to go too hard
there but the club itself was amazing it
was like a jungle inside like vines Holt
and flying down and I had fake plants
and real plants and steam coming from
the ground so it was like you're in the
rainforest in Brazil but you're in Tokyo
and one eye jack and the girls were
extremely good-looking they surprised
you as well they really did
multicultural people from all over your
or the world everything right so I was
like wow I this is some quality this is
a quality place guys walk in I do see
SAP writes apps got $1,000 a hundred
thousand yen in front of like a stack
which is hilarious you looked at and he
just has a static stack in front of him
at the table as he's wearing his karate
kid' bandanas because he did not wear it
the whole week so your first thought was
oh saps been here for a while
yes I'm like this apps app had made this
corner his corner and he was he was
having fun and of course he's talking
loud or whatever so okay great
we're sitting there hanging out and I'm
having a lot of fun but I start to
realize you know this is a Super Bowl
champs and I started to hear guys going
screw curfew tonight we still had kerf
and what time was curfew like 11 o'clock
you got bed check I mean the night
hasn't even started no 11 o'clock right
right and it's like 11:00 and I start to
hear some of the vets and I'm not naming
any names right
other than Dwight because I know
Dwight's fine with this but they're all
gone let's skip it let's skip let's
cooker for you tonight let's skip carpi
tonight
you know Mike so what's what do you feel
I'm rookie dumbass here I'm just going
like they're skipping cool sounds good
so I'm off in this little era other area
of the the strip club now because I've
made my decision since I heard some of
the vets are not going I'm not going
either
yes I don't care I'm the third-string
nobody I'm not going to curfew like I'm
with the cool kids
sounds good I'm not gonna get in trouble
plus I'm a quarterback exactly right
more and more kind of already packed it
up I'm not going to curfew like I am in
the other side I'm talking to one of the
females that works there yeah very
beautiful girl yeah and I'm like
entranced of their I'm looking long I'm
gonna talk to her for the next four
hours I'm like why are you not working
on Holly in Hollywood I was like she was
that kind of pretty yeah all of a sudden
I hear loudmouth and I'm like is that
SAP like coming around the corner are
you just here I didn't hear it and he's
getting closer to me somebody must have
told him I was still there and shimmery
shimmer shimmer shut around I hear him
and all sudden he kind of turns around
the corner hey get your you've got 12
minutes get your [ __ ] ass out
of here
get your I'm not getting in trouble for
you missing curfew stupid ass rookie
buh-buh-buh he went in on me
and you know of course I got home just
in time really but there was yes that
was my first instance because the next
morning I remember waking up we had to
get down to the bus at like a decent
hour and I could see that you know
Gruden his right-hand man there was
definitely some egg
about the team and that some guys that
they thought would never miss curfew
miss curfew they called his bluff but
man that was a night I'll never forget
did you did you hear stories the next
day really like what I miss what do they
know nothing I didn't miss anything I
don't think it around breaking that
woman is now your wife I'm just kidding
I think Josh did he do it yes Jack look
it up I wonder if it is ano that was the
same night I heard the Keshawn story
right I've told you that one right we
said that before okay so he Shawn played
for the Jews told this one I have well
I'll tell it again
in case you ever lose it we Keyshawn
played for the Jets of course was traded
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers Rich McKay was
a GM Keyshawn was holding court and
Keyshawn was a really good NFL receiver
I mean he really was I don't care what
anybody says is he a hall-of-famer no
but he was really damn good and he was
tough and fearless but he thought a lot
of himself too
and I'm gonna tell this story but he was
trying to hold court with some of the
Jets and Bucs players about telling them
I'm better than tio and you know guys
are sitting there and we know it's
Keyshawn and that's the way he talked
some time I'm better than G oh I'm
better than three over a decade one-eyed
Jack has become synonymous with the
glitz and glamour of Tokyo they're on
the Internet Jana if you want to apply
to be a hostess they're taking anyway so
rich McKay that's amazing so rich McKay
is walking by and he Shaun's holding
court and he cuts rich over rich rich
rich because he thinks rich is gonna be
his guy and tell the story the way he
wants it he goes rich rich who's better
between me or tio and he looks at
Keyshawn he goes man Keyshawn you're
really good when you catch the ball it's
first down but man when tio catches the
ball it's touchdown and I mean when I
tell you said the place the the popped
off we laughed so hard at that and
Keyshawn handled it great yeah he's just
wanting this rich it's like you know a
pasty you know pasty owner yeah yeah
britches that's a good line though
there's a great line first first down
speaking of touchdowns yeah I think
Manziel is gonna throw a bunch on Friday
our embedded
Canadian reporter Conor O'Neill says
he's starting on Friday I know
I don't think they're a very good team
no I don't think so I don't really care
what his stats are I am excited to watch
him you're gonna check it out I am
definitely not gonna be on TV I don't
know but I mean either way I'm just
going to do my best on the internet TV
yeah I want to see where he's at I want
to see if he can still run the way you
still I want to see what his throwing
looks like all that stuff thought I'd be
on espn2 according to Georgia I got some
great uniforms I know that the Montreal
Eliam Alouettes I like him he looks good
in that deuce with that blue and red
stripe and everything he looks cool it
will be his first time starting a game
since December 27 2015 for the Cleveland
Browns alright I got a few fans stuff
before we get out of here just the
longest podcast no I don't think so it's
not Josh shut up the bratty ag-3 says
I'd like to here take of this color us
jerseys are gone what do you think a
throwback uniforms on Thursday Night
Football
Texans koware Oilers pats where the guy
with the guy's squatting I love that I
like that too I like I'm not gonna say
and loved all color rush uniforms I
liked a lot of them but yeah I do I love
having the nostalgic like old-school
unify always problem with color rush is
it started with the bills Jets when they
went all red all green and it turned
into a spectacle yeah and then also the
the Jaguars mustard was always weird
yeah but I would love throwback Thursday
that would be awesome Brad that's a
great one this one's from the Jack far
can you ask Sims why when he talks about
the Saints he never mentions Pete
Carmichael and only Sean Payton Shirley
Carmichael deserves credit since he's
the OC big fan keep it all going guys
yeah he's right I should what oh but
it's still not really the OC what does
Pete Carmichael do dia thing well he's
like cuz he's listed as the OC he does a
lot of the dirty work he does do these
certainly a part of the game planning
yeah with Sean Sean's the OC but this is
a guy that's an extension of Sean that
he trusts and knows he's gonna be able
to do some of the things and even have
the same thoughts about plays they might
implement it against that scheme during
the week and I think if they're almost
like they're a tandem together but yes
you're right I don't give Carmichael but
it's like being an OC for McVeigh or a
Shanahan at that time - yeah sure there
might be a guy that has that title but
they have so much control that
they were gone it would be tough for you
to reenact yes okay this one is from you
F Jeff I have an out of Jeff Cofield
question for you
good job Jeff you've talked about our
players like Odell and Abie have their
own cook nutritionist trainer because
they can afford it compared to other
players would it make sense for teams to
include this type of package and
contract deals for certain players would
that be something players would one if
so you would think that teams could use
this in contract negotiations best from
Switzerland Jeff yeah I mean it the
first thing that came to my mind is
using that to woo undrafted free agent
yes right that because if you're getting
paid a lot of money you'll be able to
afford it right now they're gonna have
to find some way that it'll still count
against the salary cap right the NFL is
not gonna can't just throw you can't get
free chefs the best chef and we're gonna
say it's free and not count against
anything the one thing teams are trying
to do and I know this from a number
they're you know they're training tables
they have at their facilities they have
gone up a notch as far as food and yes
like there was some teams I think we're
just like hey these guys are in shape we
could serve them I was reading an
article that when Aaron Rodgers first
got to Green Bay there was an ice cream
machine and he used to eat milkshakes
all the time and that was just there
like guys got done a hard practice take
down a nice cool chocolate-vanilla swirl
what tennessee's food was like out of
this world good I couldn't wait to
practices over but it was home cooking
southern food buy my chicken meat I'm an
asset a name that was in charge of it
yes so the food was phenomenal man you
look back and you're like why was he
even yeah it didn't affect me but Albert
Haynesworth was probably like Dan that's
why I was five pounds overweight every
week but yes that and then he would bake
like him and his wife wouldn't I think
his name was Chris he make like how they
make homemade cakes and stuff so not
only did I go just like some not the TV
trends and fries and then I'd be like
man this yellow cake my personal apple
pie I'm bringing this into the meeting
with me like and I would have liked to
visas of cake that would stuff my face
with it has changed alright last one
this is from Scott three three al he got
a Bose this question if Archie Manning
had had daughters instead of sons
how many Super Bowls would Tom Brady
have at least seven maybe double digits
interesting question there's good
questions okay Manning had daughters
instead of sons yes hey Tanya and Alenia
alright how many Super Bowls with Tom
Brady yeah I mean I guess you could
certainly argue seven I mean it might be
eight really he wins both Giants games
right if he likes out there and then he
probably wins the 2006 matchup where the
Colts went on and where they were top 21
three at halftime the Colts came back to
win remember I'm talking right
no well you remember they were up at
home Manning threw the pick 6 to Curtis
this Samuels I suppose to make it 21 6
at halftime and we're going here we go
here we go the Patriots member the week
before was when San Diego had them beat
Khe Sanh intercepted the body bumbled
they went on and beat the cult I mean
they played the Colts of the Holts
remember neither one of them were the 1
or 2 seat they were the three in four
seed that year I don't remember
and the Colts got to have that AFC
championship game where they went on to
beat the Bears so there's another one
where you could say yeah wow you can
realistically see the intricate saucer
bowls they're beating the Bears I would
think so Grossman yeah definitely
so maybe eight maybe eight Archie
Manning Archie Manning does Archie
Manning go to the Hall of Fame because
of what he created plus his career you
have unbelievable semen yeah do you work
in the Hall of it that might not make
the cut he's laughing it was funny but
no Archie Manning is a guy where I look
out like my dad does does he consider a
contributor for contributing to kids do
you get contributing to Hall of Famers
as a Hall of Famer and he's Archie's the
man though alright Fenwick's in here
which means we have a meeting so we got
to go why because next week we are going
on the road we're headed off for
California to do talk to players a lot
of special thanks for Pacman Jones
coming on the show I have no doubt that
he will be on a team by the end of this
training camp yeah it's kind of a nice
tale that he's actually getting to spend
time with his kids and you know what
that Airport guy
you deserve that yes it'll Simms thank
you for bringing it as always to all the
guys getting into the Hall of Fame
congratulations grats to Brian Dawkins I
love
you with all my heart for Sims peace out
homies for federic good evening and for
the lef koe man we will holla holla
holla holla holla holla talk to you guys
what I check this place out
[Music]